it grew out of Syria's nightmare brutal
and ruthless it put down bloody roots
inside Iraq the expanding territory
under its control is now called the
Islamic states caliphate this fantasy is
now considered enough of a threat to
concentrate the minds of leaders at the
NATO summit in Wales and it's billed as
the most important in decades America
and Britain are now inching towards a
strategy to deal with the Islamic state
what we've got to do is make sure that
we are organizing the Arab world the
Middle East the Muslim world along with
the international community to isolate
this cancer in military terms there are
a wide range of options the least likely
is maintaining the limited air support
for Iraqi forces from the US and the UK
it has stemmed the Islamic state advance
but it won't be enough to destroy it so
what could be done a regional effort
could unite long-standing foes like
Saudi Arabia with Iran tie the u.s. to
Tehran on the battlefield draw Saudi
Arabia's regional rival cutter into a
military alliance and see the return of
Turkish forces to a combat role in the
former Ottoman Empire
an Arab and Muslim army on the ground
would get support from Western air and
naval forces this isn't as far-fetched
as it sounds in the last couple of weeks
American special forces and Iranian
Kurds Force commandos have been fighting
on the same side against the Islamic
state around our mele the Iranians
advise Shia militia the Americans were
embedded with Kurds and called in
airstrikes this combination ended a
siege of many weeks people who
fundamentally are threatened by Isis are
the the states in the region and I think
that we should despite the horrors of
recent beheadings we should not seek to
take the lead in responding to Isis we
should very much encourage and support
the local regions leaders in countering
this threat that is primarily to them if
the Islamic state is the threat the
government say it is then regional
powers may face little choice but to
form a once unthinkable alliance they
will be aware that the Islamic states
ambitions are huge to establish a
Caliphate over a vast empire under the
Black Flag Sam Kiely Sky News